If you want to know more about Jigsaw’s
backstory like the details only included in
the comic, and if you want to see the full
chronology of what I think is the only accurate
timeline of the events of John Kramer’s
life on the internet, then stick around to
the end of this video.
Many of my favorite horror villains are not
monsters in the typical sense of having a
scary appearance or intimidating demeanor,
but instead project more of a psychological
horror, oftentimes brought on by a distorted
sense of how they see the world.
Many of the best antagonists or anti-heroes
are scary to me because they actually believe
that they are doing the world a service with
their misdeeds, and the agent of the events
we’ve come to know as The Saw Franchise
is a model example of this chilling behaviour.
Welcome to Horror History my name is Very
****ing Confused.
“My name is very ****ing confused, what’s
your name?”
And in today’s lesson I’ll be analysing
the man responsible for years of citywide
panic, a slew of impersonators, a cult of
nefarious followers, a massive federal investigation
and most significantly the deaths of at least
57 victims.
I am of course referring to The Jigsaw Killer,
John Kramer, most commonly known by the nickname:
Jigsaw, which was originally derived from
his practice of cutting Jigsaw pieces from
the flesh of his failed victims as a symbol
for the missing piece of their survival instinct.
In this video we’re going to look at Jigsaw’s
entire life to put together those pieces,
and as with any puzzle, the best way to start
is by figuring out the adjacent pieces, the
corner pieces such as John Kramer’s past. We'll also explore
the mysteries of his background, the development
of his psychopathy, the imposition of a God-complex
with the religious parallels in his work,
and finally, the realization of his ultimate
failure.
So in order to understand how the puzzle that
is John Kramer was built, let’s take it
all the way back to his birth.
John Kramer was born in the year 1954, a fact
we are able to derive from the mention of
his age at the time of death.
“Subject’s name is John Kramer.
A 52 year old male caucasian.
So he was only in his early 50s during the
Saw movies?
YIKES.
With a capital YIKES.
Like the whole thing is capital.
John’s work consisted of a company he founded
called The Urban Renewal Group, but despite
how it sounds, this had nothing to do with
mid-2000s hip-hop.
John was a civil engineer who worked alongside
a lawyer named Art Blank to build homes for
low-income families and also sometimes created
other buildings with the intent of helping
people.
John was extremely intelligent, making him
a world class engineer, but he was also great
at understanding people and anticipating their
actions, which made him quite successful on
the business end as well.
He was quickly able to scale Urban Renewal
Group to the point that he owned several buildings
throughout the city and had a fair amount
of resources, which he channelled back into
helping the people of that city.
The desire to help improve people’s lives
was the first key moment to understand his
motivation, because it was this that drove
his actions throughout his entire life.
I would also speculate that it was the reason
he fell in love with the woman that would
become his wife, Jill Tuck, the doctor who
ran a recovery center for drug addicts known
as Homeward Bound Clinic.
The clinic’s motto was “cherish your life”
a phrase that John would also associate with
his own work.
John and Jill’s love eventually led to marriage
and plans to have a first child.
Like in his work, John meticulously planned
all aspects of his life and the baby was no
exception.
The child’s name, Gideon, was also the name
of his first building, The Gideon Meatpacking
Plant and may have been drawn from the Hebrew
name Gidon, which meant hero or judge, showing
us John’s subconscious desire to judge people
for their sins.
The baby’s planned date of birth was in
1995, the Chinese Year of the Pig, which was
a symbol of rebirth, a concept that John believed
heavily in.
The name Gideon and the pig symbol would have
greater meaning later in John’s story, but
for now, he was focused on tending to his
pregnant wife.
He would wait for her to get done with work
some days, and he noticed some shady characters
who were patients at the clinic.
One evening he has to intervene when a fight
nearly breaks out between two addicts named
Cecil Adams and Gus Colyard, and John has
to convince Cecil to put his knife away before
things get much worse.
This causes John to wonder how effective his
wife’s rehabilitation methods really are,
but he still encourages her work, something
he would come to regret later down the line.
He also displays evidence that he’s become
more jaded towards the world when he meets
an insurance mogul named William Easton, who
sponsors a party at Jill’s clinic.
They seem to connect over their mutual need
to predict human behaviour in their respective
jobs, but John disagrees with William’s
methods of trying to screen people and determine
their probability of illness before giving
them insurance coverage.
“But you’re not taking into consideration
the most important human element of all.”
“Which is what?”
“The will to live.”
This exchange would be another important puzzle
piece in the crafting of the Jigsaw persona,
because John believed that he was giving each
of his victims a chance to survive by putting
them through adversity.
As Gideon’s due date got closer though,
John continued to prepare for the birth of
his son by constructing a crib, a children’s
toy that resembled a ventriloquist doll, which
he would name Billy the Puppet and by creating
a home video for the boy during an ultrasound
monitoring.
Again, we can pull a couple of puzzle pieces
from John’s preparation to be a father.
The messages he meant to save for his son
were to be passed via video tape, and he would
eventually use this this medium to speak to
his test subjects, while the puppet would
be reimagined as the face of Jigsaw, an avatar
that appeared in some of the tapes and who
would sometimes make physical appearances
to carry on messages to his victims.
[Billy the Puppet laughter]
“No, that’s not creepy at all.”
Unfortunately, before John ever got to meet
his son Gideon, tragedy would strike on one
fateful night.
One evening in late 1994, John warms up the
car while his pregnant wife closes up the
clinic and notices a distressed Cecil Adams
burst out of the building.
He immediately knows something is wrong and
goes in to find Jill collapsed on the floor
after having been hit by the swinging door
when Cecil had broken in.
Jill was 7 months pregnant at this point,
so fearing for the baby’s safety, he rushes
her to a hospital.
John suffers a long evening of emotional suffering,
and Jill is shell shocked after doctors are
unable to save the baby.
This is the beginning of John’s descent,
his downward spiral, if you will, into becoming
a psychopath.
The most common characteristic of a psycho
is lack of empathy for their victims or remorse
for their actions, and we see the very beginning
of this right after the loss of Gideon, when
John changes his attitude towards the drug
addicts that he previously encouraged the
idea of helping.
“All I wanted to do was help them.”
“You can’t help them.
They have to help themselves.”
Trauma induced psychopathy is one of the three
major ways known to develop the condition,
and for John, losing the son he had already
committed so much devotion to was the distressing
catalyst that set things into motion.
We see how much it affected him by the fact
that he buried Gideon and marked the spot
with a tombstone, a practice not normally
used for a miscarriage.
Even those closest to him, like his wife and
his business partner were not in contact with
him, which worried them.
They decided to get together to confront him,
and find him sleeping in a chair at his workshop
in Gideon Meat Packing Plant.
He's very unwelcoming towards them, showing
no desire to return to his normal life.
Art encourages him to channel his negative
energy into their Urban Renewal Project, where
his designs would have been used to help
low-income families, but he forfeits his shares
in the company to Jill, and angrily tells
them to get out.
He had accomplished many things at this point
in his life, but none of them had been enough
to save his family from the unpredictable
crimes of a drug addict, and in his depressed
mindset, he forced himself to come up with
a solution to people like Cecil.
It was the only way he knew how to cope with
the loss.
He would use the concept of “they have to
help themselves” in his work, and in his
deranged state, he figured the first person
he should give that opportunity to was his
son’s killer.
He tracks down Cecil during a celebration
of the Chinese New Year, which, knowing John,
was likely the planned due date of Gideon.
To disguise himself, he steals a pig mask,
remember, it was Year of the Pig.
I’m just glad he upgraded to something a
little bit more spooky later on, because if I
saw my kidnapper wearing this, I’d probably
just start losing it… like what are you
going to do?
Force me to star in children’s daytime television
programming?
Actually, that does sound horrifying.
But another reason it makes sense for him
to use the pig mask was that the pig in the
Chinese Zodiac represented rebirth, and he
viewed his games as a chance for victims to
be reborn as better people.
He chloroforms Cecil, who next awakens in
John’s workshop.
“You did this to me.”
“No, you did this to yourself.”
Yeah come on Cecil.
You did this.
This was all you buddy.
He’s delusional.
Cecil is trapped in the knife chair.
John claims it is a tool to reclaim his life.
If he can press his face through a barrier
of eight knives and press a lever on the other
side his restraints will be released.
John thinks this is fitting because it will
make Cecil’s face ugly to match his greedy
soul.
Cecil is able to release himself from the
chair, but this is not enough to rehabilitate
him.
He tries to attack John, who sidesteps and
sends him tumbling into the razor wire trap,
and this one, he’s unable to escape.
John may have told himself that letting Cecil
die after giving him a second chance was a
good thing, that Cecil was unable to be rehabilitated,
and so, killing him was just.
Another trait of a psychopath is the need
for repeated stimulation.
Because John felt he was doing Cecil a favor
by putting him through his test, he soon had
the desire to "help" more people and began
to create more complex traps in his workshop.
But John's good intentions would not be enough
to make future traps fair or just, and before
long, police would recognize Kramer's actions
as the work of a serial killer.
GORDON: "Newspapers started calling him The Jigsaw Killer."
Hoping to do something about the decline of
her marriage after losing the baby she was
carrying, Jill decided to try to talk to John
and give him one more chance, so she goes
back into the workshop.
Before finding her husband, she discovers
reconnaissance photos of Cecil Adams.
Cecil was believed to be missing, and Jill
wondered if John had anything to do with it.
He finds her snooping around and becomes very
angry with her, telling her not to ever come
back, effectively the end of their relationship,
and another sign of psychopathic behavior,
impulsivity.
They would get divorced not long after.
After Jill leaves, he goes back to work on
another trap, the glass coffin.
This box would allow the user to be transported
out of a collapsing room and brought to safety.
John wouldn't survive long enough to use this
himself.
Instead, it would be used years later by his
successor, but the fact that he was working
on it way back in the 90s is a testament to
John's intelligence and ability to predict
possible outcomes, one of the things that
makes him so dangerous as a serial killer.
Despite his impressive intellect, his physical
condition was about to worsen, as John was
diagnosed with colon cancer not long after
the divorce.
Between the divorce and the cancer diagnosis,
this was two straight tragedies for John.
The cancer got to him while he was already
at the lowest of low points, and as a result,
he decided to end his life.
He decides to do this Groundhog Day style,
by driving his car off a cliff, but miraculously,
he survives the wreck.
As he is lying in the smoking mess, he realizes
that he wants to live, and in order to do
so, he must endure a little more pain by pulling
a stake out of himself to escape.
Not only was this a revelation for John in
that he got to experience first hand how testing
his own will to live had supposedly healed
his mind and given him newfound appreciation
for life, but it also may have inspired him
directly to create The Spike Trap, a trap
that would be used years later and required
the a victim to remove metal stakes from herself
in order to escape; and the Horsepower Trap,
where a victim literally experiences a car
crash.
MEME GIRL: "Here's. The motherf"
*Huge Crash*
🎵 "Don't stop, keep going." 🎵
After walking away from his self-imposed car
wreck, his faith in the rehabilitation method
he had tried on Cecil was restored, and he
may have realized that the pain factor would
need to be amplified, because in order for
it to work, the traps would need to test the
very fabric of human nature.
He got to work on some new traps as he was
being treated at the Angel of Mercy Hospital,
where he ended up being unsatisfied with the
hospitality of almost everyone working there,
and marked them in his mind as future victims
to be rehabilitated.
The people he encountered there were mostly
just doing their jobs, but because John was
becoming more frustrated by the tragedies
of his life, he was looking too hard for victims
to punish by finding reasons that weren't
really there.
Over the course of the next 5-7 years, John
began to pay more attention to the world around
him as he continued to receive chemotherapy
for his colon cancer.
He came to meet some of the other people who
he deemed as unappreciative of their lives
and planned to include them in his upcoming
test game.
A game, in his eyes, was a series of different
traps involving multiple people, that was
supposed to add a social experiment element
to his patented rehabilitation process.
OK, it wasn’t really patented.
I just thought that word sounded good there
to be honest.
He had hoped to do more than simply spend
his time testing a series of individuals until
his time on this Earth expired.
Instead, he wanted to create a long-lasting
societal change that would impact people long
after his passing, by running his games and
letting a survivor go on to tell the tale
of their trial.
When news of the horrors they experienced
broke, others would be less likely to make
the same mistake out of fear of becoming the
next victim.
John wanted to turn one random act of supposed
vigilante justice into an entire movement,
but soon found it could become even more than
that.
He decided to hold his first game as a test,
and so, created and ran it in secret at a
remote location, an abandoned pig farm that
was still owned by his wife's family.
He thought this was the perfect choice because
it fit his idea of the pig icon representing
rebirth.
Some of the victims of this test game were
people in his life at the time.
This first game was a bit different than the
others, in that it was more about getting
the victims to admit the mistakes of their
past.
The later games were more about putting the
perpetrators in physical pain, which is usually
somehow symbolic of their wrongdoing.
There would be five players included in the
Barn Game.
There was Ryan, whose foolish actions got
his friends killed back in high school; Carly,
a thief who caused her victim to have an asthma
attack; Mitch, who sold a faulty motorcycle
resulting in the death of John's nephew; Anna,
who was John's next door neighbor and was
normally very supportive of him while going
through chemotherapy, but who also killed
her baby and blamed it on her sleeping husband
and Logan Nelson, a resident of Angel of Mercy
Hospital who accidentally switched the labels
of John's brain scan with that if another
patient, which delayed the diagnosis of a
tumor on John's brain.
As a result of this, he wasn't correctly diagnosed
until 2003, and by that point it's too late.
The physicians working on his case, Dr. Lawrence
Gordon and Dr. Lynn Denlon were cold and unsympathetic
to him during his treatment, and John did
not like the way Dr. Gordon told him how long
he had to live.
He planned to possibly test the two doctors
in future games, but for now, he had collected
enough players to run his test game, so he
collected them, brought them to the Tuck Pig
Farm and John Kramer's first experiment began.
JIGSAW: "Any attempt to violate my rules will kill
you.
I want to play a game."
When the game begins, John keeps track of
the progress of each player by monitoring
the rooms with security cameras.
Later iterations of the games would have him
physically present to make sure that the rules
of each game are followed, so I'm guessing
that technology was used here in the test
game because two of the contestants, Anna
and Logan, already knew who John Kramer was.
“Hello Anna.”
“John?”
Each player wakes up with a bucket on their
head and is instructed to make a blood sacrifice,
but Logan didn't wake up at the same time
as the others, giving him an unfair disadvantage.
John recognises this, and doesn't think it
would be right for Logan to die because of
a small mistake, so he stops the spinning
saw blades and bails him out.
Logan had suffered large lacerations across
his back, but with John's help, he's able
to have them stitched up and he survives.
From there, the rest of the game plays out
as planned until there are only two survivors
remaining, Anna and Ryan.
Wearing the updated version of the pig mask,
John re-enters the game and once more
sedates them.
While they are unconscious, he moves them
to another part of the barn called the slaughter
room.
If you're wondering if there's a reason it's
called that, there is.
And there's about to be a second one.
Ryan and Anna are locked to opposite sides
of the room and John finally reveals himself
to deliver the rules of this final challenge.
JIGSAW: "Now The game is simple.
The best ones are.
You have one shotgun.
You have one shell."
He doesn’t specifically tell them that the
gun is configured backwards.
The theme of this game from the beginning
was for them to find salvation by looking
inwards.
JIGSAW: "While I am certain that there is a desire to point
fingers at me for the blood that has been
shed, unless you turn that finger inward,
I assure you more blood will be lost.”
The same principle ends up applying for the
gun.
JIGSAW: “Now if you want to achieve your freedom,
you have to learn.
You have to realize that you’ve been doing
it backwards.”
...so when Anna fails to take these clues
into consideration and tries killing Ryan
with the gun, she ends up shooting herself.
The key that would have released them was
also hidden in the bullet casing left inside
the gun, so it is destroyed when Anna shoots
it and so are Ryan's chances of ever escaping.
That leaves only one survivor of the test
game, Logan Nelson, and he would actually
be the one to give shape to the next piece
of the Jigsaw puzzle.
Let's just go back just one moment to the point
where John Kramer reveals himself in a game
for the first time.
When he comes out to address Ryan and Anna,
he's wearing a new costume, a hooded robe
that almost makes him look like a monk or
priest.
This pig farm was no temple, but the attire
does lead me into the next piece of the Jigsaw
puzzle: the religious aspect of John's teachings.
When I said he was creating a movement, it's
wasn't only about scaring the citizens into
behaving as he wants them to, based on the
cautionary tales of the survivors; but he
also wanted to develop his own cult, his own
group of followers that could pass down his
teachings and eventually take over for him
when he was gone.
In order to truly change the world, he would
have to create something that would still
inspire this behaviour for future generations,
and the only way to do that was for his followers
to pass down his values.
“Change da world.
My final message.
Goodbye.”
The first step to doing this is by painting
himself as a religious leader by wearing these
robes.
In doing so, he started to see himself as
a God.
As discussed in the Horror History episode
on Mark Hoffman, a God complex is an unshakable
belief characterized by consistently inflated
feelings of personal ability, privilege, or
infallibility.
In other words, he thinks he can do no wrong.
The religious attire was kind of a final step
towards John truly believing that he was a
God, and according to psychologist and author
Harold Kaplan's definition of a God-complex,
Jigsaw's behaviour fits to a T.
"A person with a god complex may refuse to
admit the possibility of their error or failure,
even in the face of irrefutable evidence and
intractable problems."
In John's case, look no further than his previous
trap with Cecil Adams.
He believed that if Cecil suffered through
the knife chair, he would be instantly rehabilitated.
But he wasn't, he still tried to attack John
after escaping.
But even after seeing that go down, John refuses
to believe his methods are faulty, and continues
with his plans to create new traps.
I also think it's no coincidence that Cecil's
surname is 'Adams'.
Cecil is John's first victim to be punished
for wrongdoing, and in the biblical story
of Adam and Eve, Adam is the one to take the
forbidden fruit, which gets them banned from
The Garden of Eden.
“I’m not really sure how I have to say
this but, I just have to say this so that
no one makes the same mistake I’ve done.
I’m not sure how many of you know this but
I’ve actually been permanently banned…
for life.”
Other indicators of a God-complex include
"a person highly dogmatic in their views",
meaning the person speaks of their personal
opinions as though they were unquestionably
correct.
Just listen to the way John addresses his
victims, in a booming God-like voice might
I add, as if his judgements of them are completely
irrefutable.
“You deny culpability no doubt, for the
circumstances in which you find yourselves,
salvation can be yours if you cleanse yourselves
of the habitual lies, which have brought you
here.”
He even speaks using language that you might
find in religious texts when addressing his
victims.
The final indicator of a God-complex is exhibiting
“no regard for the conventions and demands
of society.
They may request special consideration or
privileges.”
John’s methods are against the law, obviously.
He would soon start holding more public facing
games, but since he views what he’s doing
as morally just, he disregards the rules of
our society.
OFFICER RIGG: “Get his ass out of here.”
JIGSAW: “Actually, I will need to remain here while you deal with
your problem, Detective Matthews.”
So John is a textbook example of someone with
a God-complex, but a religion cannot work
with only a God or leader, it also requires
followers, and John had already found his
first one.
After saving Logan Nelson from the barn game,
he takes him under his wing and trains him
in the ways of Jigsaw.
He explains the basic concepts upon which
he operates.
Many religions use some kind of text or commandments
to impress a moral code on their followers.
Jigsaw’s games each have rules, and the
ideals expressed in these tapes serve as the
religious texts, the main method of John Kramer’s
teachings.
Most religious texts date back thousands of
years or more, and John’s teachings gain
a similar immortality when a website is founded
to spread his word even after his death.
DET. HUNT: “Uh Logan, you ever heard of a website called
Jigsaw rules?”
DET. HALLORAN: “It’s a site devoted to Jigsaw.”
And of course, the most important part of
The Cult of Jigsaw, and the Saw franchise
in general, is the traps.
In religion, there are usually abstract concepts
of sin leading to punishment.
Popular ones include heaven and hell, while
others use a system of karma and reincarnation.
John’s religion kind of combines both ideas.
The traps cause suffering, as a form of punishment
for those who have sinned, but he views this
suffering as transformative.
He thinks the survivors of his traps are reborn
as better people.
And leads us back to Logan Nelson, who would
become the first disciple of Jigsaw.
John taught him everything he believed in,
and also shared some of his knowledge in the
field of mechanical engineering.
Together, they created what would become Jigsaw’s
signature trap: The Reverse Bear Trap.
The partnership would be short lived however,
because Nelson had to go overseas to fight
in the war, so John would have to look elsewhere
to find more potential disciples.
As he is still working to fight off the cancer,
he discovers someone who he thinks could potentially
have what it takes to be one of his followers.
It all begins when John is doing some of his
own research on alternate treatments, and
discovers a doctor in Norway who has been
administering an experimental therapy with
a 30 to 40% success rate.
He goes to visit his health care provider
Umbrella Health, which is run by William Easton,
the man who had once sponsored the party at
Jill’s clinic.
He explains the situation and requests coverage,
but William gives him this copy and paste
answer about how his doctor would already
be using the treatment if it worked, how it’s
not feasible with John’s insurance policy
and that if he seeks this treatment out independently,
he’ll be dropped from his current coverage.
John responds with one of my favorite lines,
that I always make sure to quote if I ever
have to go to the doctor.
Whenever it’s time to pay, the receptionist
will just be like, “ok CZsWorld, that’s
$50,000” and then I just do my best John
Kramer voice and say, “You know, in the
far east, people pay their doctors when they’re
healthy.”
And then she’s like, “what?”
And I say, “You think it’s the living
that will have ultimate judgement over you...”
No, but I think the reason John reacts the
way he does to Mr. Easton is more out of principle,
to make a point about the healthcare system
rather than for personal reasons.
I think he knew he was going to die before
long, and he had the money to seek out other
treatments, but he wanted his legacy to say
something about society, which is again, something
that a religious icon might do.
Later that year, things would get worse with
his health once again, and it was time to
unleash the Jigsaw icon out into the world.
The public was about to learn of Jigsaw for
the first time.
In June of 2003, Dr. Lawrence Gordon diagnosed
John with an Inoperable Frontal Lobe Tumor,
or Glioblastoma Multiforme of the left temporal
lobe.
In other words, he had a very fast spreading
brain cancer.
He underwent chemotherapy to try to kill the
cancer cells and external beam radiation therapy
to try and remove the tumor.
Nine months later, on March 24th 2004, John
was found to have progressive aphasia and
right-sided hemiplegia.
That means the brain cancer was affecting
his ability to speak, and also limiting his
ability to move the right side of his body.
See, we’re learning science as well here
in the Horror History classroom.
This show is educational guys.
It’s not just memes.
*building laughter and chest opening music*
"Wait till you see the...
"Oh no, no, no, no!"
*building laughter and chest opening music*
*EXPLOSION OF SQUEALING LAUGHTER*
OK fine, but my point is, it’s not all memes.
John was examined again and Dr. Gordon and
Dr. Denlon discovered a mass on his left temporal
lobe causing his brainstem to compress.
The cancer was also Metastatic, meaning it
was moving to different parts of the brain
or possibly different parts of the body.
A further brain scan indicated signs of necrosis;
his brain cells were going to die as a side
effect of the radiation therapy which was
meant to kill the cancer cells, but didn’t
necessarily distinguish between good and bad
cells.
In addition to that, he exhibited edema, so
his brain was swelling inside of his skull,
forcing them to perform a craniotomy, a brain
surgery that requires them to create a surgical
opening through his skull.
If you weren’t paying attention through
most of that medical jargon, basically all
you need to know is ya boy was sick, and Dr.
Denlon told him, “there’s no preventative
treatment for what you have”, in a very
cold clinical tone.
John didn’t appreciate that a whole lot.
His brain may have had a recurring tumor,
but it didn’t seem to affect his memory,
as he would file Dr. Denlon’s lack of empathy
away in his mind to make her another possible
test subject in the future.
In the meantime however, Dr. Gordon and Dr.
Denlon were able to improve his condition
enough so that he could be released from the
hospital to enjoy what time he had left at
home.
However he had other ideas of how he wanted
to spend his precious hours.
Ironically, we don’t actually see his first
public victims, even though this area in between
March 2004 and October 2004 has been covered
to death in the movies.
But basically what we do know is that there
were at least three-or-so traps that were held
in which none of the victims made it.
The reason I think this is because the next
death that we do see is the death of Seth
Baxter in the Pendulum Trap, which was created
by Detective Mark Hoffman to make it look
like Seth was another victim of Jigsaw.
But in order for this copycat crime to make
sense, that means there had to have been other
Jigsaw traps that were discovered by the public
in the first place.
Even though we don’t see them on this list
of Jigsaw victims in Saw 5.
Maybe there’s another page to this list
that we don’t see, or maybe they were all
so badly mutilated that they could not be
identified.
It certainly wasn’t because the creators
of this franchise are human, and a mistake
was made.
In these first three public victims, a few
conventions are established, like the use
of a pre-recorded tape featuring Billy the
Puppet reading the rules of each trap out
to the victim, the idea that John is physically
present at the site of each test, and the
fact that a jigsaw puzzle piece is cut out of the
flesh of each subject.
As a result of this, the police and the press
coined the name Jigsaw and John became known
as The Jigsaw Killer.
“My name’s John.”
“I thought you liked to be called Jigsaw.”
“It was the police and the press who coined
the nickname Jigsaw. I never encouraged or claimed that.
The Jigsaw piece I cut from my subjects was
only ever meant to be a symbol that that subject
was missing something.”
Mark Hoffman used these elements in his copycat
Jigsaw trap, but John had already been keeping
an eye on him for other reasons, so he found
out immediately, and decided to test him as
well in a crude trap called the shotgun chair,
which prevented Hoffman from moving his arms
if he didn’t want to… you know… blow
his head off.
The reason Hoffman is tested is that he didn’t
give his subject a second chance.
“EVERYBODY DESERVES A CHANCE!”
...And you get a chance!
And you get a chance! Hoffman is gonna get
one too, because John realizes that the two
of them are not too far apart in their intentions.
They both want to bring justice to the city,
but John believes he has a better way of going
about it because of his God-complex.
So he brings Hoffman on as his next disciple.
To make sure he stays in line, John threatens
that the truth about Hoffman being Seth Baxter’s
killer will automatically be released if anything
happens to him.
So Hoffman is forced to work under John, and
John hopes that this will help him see the
light, and starts to agree with John’s methods.
In order to start this transformation, John
takes Hoffman along as he sets up the next
two traps.
The two of them double team a man named Paul
Leahy and leave him in The Razor Wire Maze
trap.
Paul was a former addict that John had first
met at Jill’s clinic, and had since turned
to cutting himself to feed his addiction.
The maze seems to be an updated version of
Cecil’s second trap, and Paul was required
to crawl through, thus cutting himself again
to get out.
JIGSAW: “The irony, is that if you want to die,
you just have to stay where you are.
But if you want to live, you’ll have to
cut yourself again.”
The hope was that this more painful punishment
would get Paul to appreciate the life he had,
but, it was once again in vain, and Paul was
unable to survive.
The crime scene was "investigated"
by Hoffman, but the deputy coroner
on the police force, Allison Kerry introduced
two new investigators to the equation, Stephen
Sing and David Tapp.
Jigsaw would keep tabs on them from here on
out and later decided to make them future
Jigsaw victims.
Before this, I think you could make the argument
at least that everyone he had tested… even
if you don’t want to say they deserved it,
they were bad people.
(Not including Nelson, who really didn’t
end up getting tested.)
But Sing and Tapp only end up on Jigsaw’s
naughty list because they’re trying to bring
a serial killer to justice.
This is both the psychopathy and God-complex
inside of John really taking over and skewing
his perception of reality.
These two psychological conditions cause him
to invent reasons to punish Sing and Tapp
so that nobody can stop him.
He tried to tell himself that they deserved
to be tested because they valued the glory
of catching Jigsaw over the preservation of
human life.
But it was really just an excuse to strike
down those who opposed him.
So the God-complex told him that nobody should
threaten his power, but his psychopathy told
him he was doing the right thing by putting
them through nearly inescapable tests.
John set up a new workshop in an abandoned
mannequin factory on Stygian Street.
There, he would work on the creation of his
next major game, The Bathroom Game, and he
would create a trap for Sing and Tapp, so
that they would be killed if they tried to
confront or stop him.
He does this by filming the video tapes he
plays for his victims in front of recognizable
graffiti to lure the two cops into his territory,
but they would not show up there for at least
a few weeks.
In the meantime, he had another subject to
test, and once again enlisted the help of
Hoffman.
The victim was named Mark Wilson.
John had found out that Mark was faking an
illness in order to scam others, so he tests
him using the Flammable Jelly Trap.
Mark needed to obtain the combination to a
safe containing an antidote, by using a candle
to read the clues written on the walls.
The floor was covered in sharp glass, and
one wrong move would ignite the flammable
jelly smeared over his body.
That!
Is why it’s called: The Flammable Jelly
Trap.
After setting this trap up, Hoffman tries
to warn John that Tapp is onto him, but John,
the manipulative mastermind that he is, is
already one step ahead of him.
One day during his treatment at the Angel
of Mercy Hospital, John steals a penlight
from his oncologist, Dr. Gordon, and passes
it on to Hoffman, instructing him to leave
it behind at the Flammable Jelly Trap crime
scene in order to throw the other investigators
off.
The plan worked, and it gave John a little
bit more freedom when it came to his next
trap, which would involve two more former
patients of the Homeward Bound Clinic.
This trap would take place in May of 2004,
five months before the events of the bathroom
game.
GORDON: “That was five months ago.”
And the players this time were two drug addicts
named Amanda Young and Donnie Greco.
This is another example of Jigsaw believing
his judgements are supreme, but in reality,
the scenario he creates is unfair.
Amanda is told she must retrieve the key from
the stomach of her dead cellmate in order
to remove the reverse bear trap and prevent
it from tearing open her head.
However, when she begins she finds that Donnie
is not actually dead, just asleep, but she
has to kill him to get the key.
We’re not even at the start of the first
movie yet, and John’s already breaking his
own rules.
And very loudly yelled ones at that.
“EVERYBODY DESERVES A CHANCE!”
As I discussed in my Saw episode of Things
You Missed, it is possible that Donnie already
had a second chance in a trap of his own,
offscreen somewhere, but what’s most likely
happening here, is that Jigsaw has developed
a bit of a taste for violence through his
previous victims.
It’s another trait of the psychopath, the
need for stimulation.
Ironically, this makes him no better than
the addicts that he’s so keen on punishing,
because they’re addicted to drugs and he’s
essentially addicted to putting people in traps.
He’s made himself the judge, jury and executioner,
and he’s begun to take joy in the power
that this gives him.
What makes this even more dangerous is that
fact that he’s super intelligent, and knows
that he has to be sneaky about what he’s
doing in order for it to continue.
At this point, Jigsaw is already a full-fledged
monster.
After Amanda unlocks the reverse bear trap
from her head, Billy the Puppet wheels up
on a tricycle and congratulates her.
JIGSAW'S VOICE: “Congratulations.
You are still alive.
Most people are so ungrateful to be alive.
But not you.
Not anymore.”
John waits in her apartment for her to get
home and tells her not to be afraid, because
her life has just begun.
Amanda would be his next disciple.
She was the first survivor of a game to actually
believe that the experience had helped her
overcome something, and felt that her days
of taking drugs were behind her now that she came
to appreciate life.
For this reason, John saw great potential
in her to be the one to continue his work,
so he began to work with her more closely
as he developed his next game, hoping to hone
her skills and get her up to speed with Hoffman.
Two weeks later in mid-to-late-May, John predicts
that Sing and Tapp are close to discovering
his workshop.
He may have known this because of his excellent
ability to anticipate the actions of others,
but may have also been aided by Hoffman, who
was still a police officer and may have been
looking over Tapp’s shoulder to warn John
about when he was getting close.
He starts wearing a bulletproof vest around
under his robes as a precaution, and kidnaps
a man named Jeff Ridenhour.
The reason that Jigsaw wanted to test Jeff
is unknown, because his tape is never discovered,
however, if we use the non-canon video game
Saw II: Flesh and Blood as clue, it would
seem that Jeff had attempted suicide, and
thus, John felt he did not cherish his life.
He imprisons Jeff in a trap known as The Drill
Chair, and waits for Sing and Tapp to find
him.
One day when he walks into his workshop, he
realizes that someone has been there, and
prepares for a confrontation.
He starts The Drill Chair by stepping on a
switch on the ground, and explains
that it will kill Jeff in 20 seconds if the
detectives can’t find the key.
So basically, they have to choose between saving
his life and capturing Jigsaw.
This is another example of him bending his
own rules to benefit himself.
Unless there’s some offscreen scene with
Jeff failing his first test, he’s not really
being given a second chance.
“EVERYBODY DESERVES A CHANCE!”
He also claims that he despises murder.
“KILLING IS DISTASTEFUL!”
OK, calm down dude, if you wake up your parents
the sleepover’s gonna be over.
But the fact that John physically starts a
machine designed to drill through Jeff’s
head is no different than him pulling a trigger
and shooting someone.
“I’ve never murdered anyone in my life.
The decisions are up to them.”
From what we can tell, Jeff never had the
option to escape as many of the others did.
Because if someone else were doing this, John
would see it as unjust.
But because Sing and Tapp are coming after
him, and he views himself as a God, he’ll
break any rules he wants to bring them down.
My favorite example of a God-complex in fiction
is Light Yagami from Death Note, and we see
a similar thing happen with him.
He starts off by only killing criminals, but
then he tries to kill the detective, L, who
tries to bring him to justice.
Jigsaw’s way of testing the two cops is
to see if they try to save Jeff or capture
Jigsaw.
Sing focuses on freeing the victim, but Tapp
goes after John, and as a result, fails the
test and gets his throat slashed.
Then Sing makes the same mistake and goes
after John, probably not wanting the mission
to have been in vain.
But John, who was always prepared for any
scenario, was prepared for this too.
Sing chases him down the stairs into a hallway,
where the Quadruple Gun trap is set up.
This one is pretty simple, if you trip a hidden
fishing wire, these guns hidden overhead will
kill you.
John steps over the wire safely, and Sing
shoots him with his own gun.
John’s bulletproof vest absorbs the gunshot,
but he wisely stays on the ground and waits
for Sing to approach, trip the wire, and get
himself killed…
"Game. Over. Hahahahahahahahahaha!"
...before getting back up and fleeing the
workshop for good.
I think one of the reasons he believed he’d
be able to pull something like this off, was
that he had endured so much pain from his
cancer treatment, that getting knocked to
the ground with a gunshot impact, even at
the frail age of 50 at this point, was not
much in comparison.
He expresses a similar sentiment during another
game a year later.
“I don't intend to mock you, officer…
but I'm a cancer patient.
How could you possibly put me in any more
pain… than I'm already in?”
Detective Tapp ends up surviving the throat
slash, so John has to abandon his workshop
at the mannequin factory and relocate to a
property that would later be called The Nerve
Gas House.
I would theorize that this was part of the
Urban Renewal project, the housing project
he abandoned at the end of his engineer career.
There seem to be several of these houses throughout
the city, but this particular one has been
outfitted with a network of underground tunnels
and hidden rooms, and one of these rooms was
a dilapidated bathroom that John had perfectly
configured to the site of the next big game.
If Jigsaw’s life is a puzzle, a combination
of the various pieces that make up his identity,
we need to assemble those pieces in order
to fully understand him.
The same approach can be taken to understand
some of his games.
The Barn Game brought together people who
had wronged others but refused to admit their
mistakes and seeked a confession from each
of them.
They were all unified by that, but were otherwise
not connected in any significant way.
So for John’s next game, the Bathroom Game
of October 2004, he strategically chose subjects
who were all different pieces of the same
puzzle, and the centerpiece that connected
to all the others was his oncologist at the
Angel of Mercy Hospital, Dr. Lawrence Gordon.
The first subject that John captured for this
game was named Zep Hindle.
He was an orderly at the hospital who actually
cared for John a lot and treated him well,
but unfortunately for him, John kind of needed
him to make the whole thing work.
We don’t find out why Zep was tested by
Jigsaw, however, this is another one where
we can turn to the supplemental non-canon
material for possible clues.
Saw: Rebirth was a comic and eventually motion
comic that aimed to give a little more backstory
about John Kramer.
This isn’t an official entry in the series,
because it does contradict details from some
of the movies, but I think it’s relatively
harmless to use it’s explanation of why
Jigsaw decided to test Zep.
I’m gonna roll the clip, but as a fair warning,
the casting of the voices isn’t the best.
The first voice you’re gonna hear is supposed
to be Zep and the narrator is John Kramer.
So with that in mind, let’s roll the clip.
“I bet the doc was a real shoulder to cry
on huh?
Cold hearted bastards the lot off them.”
“What are you talking about?”
“They’re all screwing around on their
wives.
I sure won’t be that way when I’m a doctor.”
“The orderly had issues of his own.
Now that my own life was slipping away, I
paid closer attention to the lives of others.”
So it seems like Zep’s big flaw was that
he was a gossip.
Jigsaw injects him with a poison and forces
him to help facilitate the game if he wants
to get the antidote.
Zep was most likely responsible for kidnapping
Dr. Gordon, while Amanda’s job was to get
Adam Stanheight.
Adam was a photographer hired by Detective
Tapp to spy on Gordon, because Tapp suspected
Gordon of being Jigsaw.
Before Amanda abducted him though, John performs
a ceremony to celebrate her rebirth.
The ceremony seems to be another example of
John trying to make his MO into a religious
experience.
He dons the black and red robes yet again
in a candle lit room and asks her to essentially
make vows of devotion to him.
Interestingly, in the Saw III official soundtrack,
the music that plays during this scene is
called “Baptism,” and if you listen closely,
there’s a choral chant in the background,
giving the feeling of a church choir.
🎵 "Baptism" - Charlie Clouser 🎵
He leaves Amanda to it, and heads to The Bathroom
to make the final preparations.
When she shows up with the unconscious Adam,
he pauses the Glam & Gore tutorial he was
watching…
He instructs her on what
to do with Adam as he pours a bucket of fake
blood on the ground and prepares himself for
his most ambitious game yet.
“It’s time to start our game.”
Oh boy, I’ll get the controllers!
TAPP: "I won't play your game. I won't!
Aughhh!"
CZ (v/o): Ohhhh wait.
I think I misunderstood.
John injects himself with a serum that is
supposed to slow down his heart rate, relax
his muscles and make him less noticeable as
a he pretends, key word: pretends, to be dead
on the floor in the middle of the bathroom
and Amanda takes all the other materials,
hits the light and closes the door on Lawrence,
Adam and John, who has a gun in his left hand
and a tape recorder in the other.
It would seem that he’s also hiding a small
remote in his palm or something, that has
the ability to send a shock to Adam or Lawrence
all Jose Altuve style.
The goal for Lawrence in this game was to
kill Adam before time runs out, and the goal
for Adam was just to escape.
He was tested because he spent more time spying
on other people than examining his own life.
Adam and Gordon are supposed to be enemies
in this game, but they try to secretly work
together to escape, not knowing that the man
in the center of the room is alive, listening,
and also the man responsible for their imprisonment.
So when they develop a plan to make it look
like Lawrence had killed Adam with the poison
to try to fool Zep, who was watching via the
camera, it doesn’t work, because John hears
everything they said, and shocks Adam to show
Zep that he wasn’t really dead.
Later, when Lawrence seems to have lost all
hope, Jigsaw gives him a buzz
which I saw as him trying one last ditch effort
to reinvigorate Gordon’s passion, to make
him stop feeling sorry for himself and to ignite
a fury to motivate him to try to pass his test.
I’d say it works.
OK, fine, roll the clip one last time.
*screaming like a madman*
That never gets old.
Gordon ends up cutting off his own foot to
escape the shackle, and in one desperate final
attempt to save his family, pretends to kill
Adam again, this time using the gun.
I find it very interesting that John doesn’t
use the electric shock again to test if Adam
is really dead.
It might be that he actually doesn’t suspect
it.
The first time, he knew to be skeptical because
he could hear Lawrence and Adam whispering
to each other in the dark.
But on the second attempt, I’m pretty sure that
Dr. Gordon just gives Adam a wink; I’ve
theorized that it’s while his head is turned
away from the camera right here.
John has to keep his eyes closed, so he doesn’t
know that this was another fake out attempt,
and Lawrence’s acting was good enough to
sell that it was real.
I know there are going to be people who think
it’s out of character for someone as smart
as John to be fooled like that, so if you
have your own theory as to why he didn’t
shock Adam right here, let me know if the
comments.
At the end of the game, Dr. Gordon is the
only one who manages to limp away alive, and
that leaves Adam alone in the bathroom with
John, who Adam still believes to be dead.
Then, this happens.
I swear, this isn’t the beginning of a mattress
commercial, THIS IS WHAT ACTUALLY HAPPENS…...
And if you do get a mattress commercial, I
swear it’s a complete coincidence.
After getting to his feet, Jigsaw informs
Adam that the key to his chain was inside
the bathtub, which was now unreachable because
the tub had drained.
Adam tries to grab Zep’s gun off the ground
to attack Jigsaw, but one last electric shock
sends it flying from his hands.
JIGSAW: “Game over.”
ADAM: (YouTube Poop scream)
John was now out of danger, but he was not
done with his tasks for that evening.
He leaves the bathroom to go find Dr. Gordon.
After seeing the way the Dr. had handled the
situation under pressure, he realized he would
be an excellent ally, and having passed his
test, he’d be a prime candidate to become
a new disciple.
He catches up to him, and finds him on the
verge of passing out because of the blood loss.
John splashes some water on his face while
congratulating him on surviving.
He helps clean up the wound and eventually
physically rehabilitates him, giving him a
prosthetic foot and taking him on as his next
accomplice.
John would treat Dr. Gordon differently than
his other students.
He was already beginning to sense potential
problems with Mark and Amanda, who he suspected
of having dark ulterior motives to harm the
victims of the traps rather than save them.
He feared that his platform, the name Jigsaw,
could be misused after his passing, so using
Dr. Gordon, he set up a system of checks and
balances.
By keeping Gordon’s involvement a secret
from the other apprentices, he had a hidden
weapon to help preserve his legacy.
I should note that Nelson was still overseas
fighting in America’s Iraq war, so John
didn’t know if he’d be coming back or
if he would be reliable anymore.
At some point over the next year, Jigsaw continues
carrying out smaller traps to test the people
he deems to have lost their appreciation for
life.
One of these is a woman named Joan, who survived
her trap, but decided not to become one of
Jigsaw’s followers for unknown reasons.
She does, however, gain a stronger appreciation
for her life, and tells her story on the news.
"That pure horror of absolute horror gave me light,
and as wrong as this may seem, I'm better for enduring it."
The broadcast reaches a man named Bobby Dagen,
who is inspired by her transformation and,
perhaps more significantly, her potential
marketability.
The smart thing for Bobby to do would be to
get in contact with her and offer to ghost-write
a book about her Jigsaw experience for a percentage
of the profits, but what he does instead is
write his own book, where he pretends to be
a Jigsaw victim.
John takes issue with this for similar reasons
to him taking issue with Hoffman impersonating
one of his traps, and confronts him at a book
signing.
“In Ancient Egypt, if you were speaking
under oath, you were required to say, ‘if
I’m lying, take me to the quarries.’
That mean anything to you?”
After getting his copy signed, John removes
the cover, with the photo of Bobby’s face
on it, telling him that he wouldn’t need
it now that they’ve met.
I think that this is John’s little way of
telling Bobby that he’s the real Jigsaw.
Obviously Bobby isn’t supposed to figure
it out right away, but he’s basically saying
that he’s so intelligent, that he’ll always
remember Bobby’s face, even from such a
short meeting, and he’s kind of hinting
that they could meet again.
They don’t meet again though, the task of
testing Bobby Dagen would fall on one of Jigsaw’s
disciples.
The next big game John would plan would be
even more complex than the last.
This game would involve two locations, and
as with the bathroom game, he planned to place
himself in the center of one of them to facilitate
things.
He also placed Amanda in the midst of the
action in the other location to make sure
that rules were followed.
Around October of 2005, it was finally time
for the game to take place.
The first half of the game, which was created
by Jigsaw, takes place in the previously mentioned
Nerve Gas House, and contained a series of
criminals who all had ties to one cop named
Eric Matthews.
One of these criminals was a con man named
Obi Tate, who John convinced to help kidnap
the other seven players.
Then, John brought in Hoffman to sedate and
bring in Obi as the eighth and final contestant.
After some finishing touches to one of the
traps within the game called the Magnum Eyehole,
the Nerve Gas House was ready.
In this game, each member was breathing in
a deadly nerve gas, and was tasked with completing
a trap of their own to win an antidote.
Each of them was a real criminal who was framed
for a different crime they did not commit
by Eric Matthews, except for one.
Daniel Matthews was Eric Mathews son.
He was also a criminal, although his crimes
were much more childish.
Part of the game involved them all figuring
out that they were tied to Matthews in some
way.
The second half of the game was created by
Amanda.
So Amanda was inside of John’s portion of
the game, and John was inside Amanda’s portion.
The second half took place at an unused Steel
Plant called Wilson Steel, which had been
the location of John’s main workshop over
the last year.
Amanda, possibly with the help of John, had
set up video monitors of the events that had
already taken place at the Nerve Gas House.
This was the main motivation for Detective
Matthews to participate in the game.
He would see his son in danger and be forced
to play along.
To add insult to injury, he re-recorded Daniel’s
voicemail greeting…?
JIGSAW: “You’ve reached Daniel’s phone, he’s
not in right now.
But if you--”
That actually brings up a lot of questions
for me.
Like, did he re-record the voicemails of every
victim?
And if so, why wasn’t that included as bonus
content on the special edition DVDs of each
Saw movie?
“Promotional DVD.”
JIGSAW: "Hello. You've reached the phone of Zac Morris. He's not in right now cause he didn't agree with my opinion on Saw 7.
Amanda is able to get Daniel through John’s
half of the game at the Nerve Gas House, and
Daniel is stowed safely and secretly within
Jigsaw’s headquarters.
But to lure Detective Matthews into his trap,
John uses another trap, which contains a clue
about the location of Jigsaw’s workshop.
Jigsaw would, for the first time in his known
history, enlist the help of his secret asset,
Dr. Lawrence Gordon for one of his traps.
The victim this time was named Michael Marks,
a police informant who was another former
patient of Homeward Bound clinic.
Jigsaw felt Michael was not worthy of the
life he’d been given because as an informant,
he spent all his time spying on others and
had become a rat or a snitch.
This shows us that Jigsaw has gone even further
down the rabbit hole.
John does exactly what Michael Marks does
to find victims who he believes are wrong
do-ers.
If anything, John himself is more guilty of
this because of the number of people he’s
keeping tabs on.
But his reasoning goes back, once again, to
the God-complex, causing him to believe that
he’s allowed to do it, but others, or society
as a whole, is not.
Michael wakes up wearing a device around his
neck called the Venus Fly Trap, which will
clamp down and impale his face if he’s unable
to obtain the key, which Gordon has hidden
behind his right eye.
Jigsaw asks him to look inward, rather than
outward, and give up one of the eyes that
he relies on so much to spy on criminals.
Michael fails his test, and John takes a Jigsaw
piece out of him and leaves a message behind
for Detective Matthews, telling him to look
closer.
I also wonder if his mis-spelling of Matthews's
last name was another sign that the brain
cancer was really getting to his head.
Matthews would take a closer look, and discover
that the victim was one of his informants,
and that the steel used to construct the trap
was from Wilson Steel Plant, a location that
John knew Matthews was familiar with because
it played a part in a case from his past.
Matthews leads his team there just in time
to catch Jigsaw eating his Sunday morning
Cocoa Puffs.
"I am cuckoo for Cocoa Puffs. I'M CUCKOO FOR COCOA PUFFS! CUCKOO FOR COCOA PUFFFS!!"
*maniacal laughing* I’m sorry, I’m just imagining
John Kramer doing that.
*more laughter*
Just seeing this old cancer patient just start
jumping around and losing it when he tastes
the Cocoa--
The SWAT team comes in and handcuffs Jigsaw.
Matthews mocks him by learning in and saying,
“Is this close enough?”
ADAM: “Uhm… yeah.”
Matthews orders his men to book Jigsaw, but
as I mentioned earlier in this lesson, John
takes control of the situation by saying he’ll
have to stay in place.
The cops find the video monitors and John
confirms that the kid seen on the screens
is indeed Matthews’s son Daniel.
His facial expression as he does this is a
sick example of how his psychotic tendencies
have evolved.
I spoke earlier about the increasing need
for repeated stimulation sometimes seen in
psychopaths.
This occurs because at the beginning, John
believed he was doing the world a service
by punishing criminals and other people he’s
judged to have lost their way.
He tortured these individuals using his traps,
and so his brain came to associate doing a
good thing with doing a very bad thing: putting
others in pain.
So as a result, he starts to like the idea
of hurting his victims.
“It’s your son Daniel, you remember him
don’t you?”
“I know who he is you piece of ****. What
is he doing on that ****ing monitor?”
“Well, I haven’t looked at the monitors
for some time, so it would be hard for me
to say, but I would imagine that he’s cowering
in a corner with a look on his face…”
“You mother****er where is he?”
And he has an even bigger smile on his face
when he describes the torture that Daniel
might be going through in detail.
He has about two hours before the gas creeping
into his nervous system begins to break down
his body tissue, and he begins to bleed from
every orpheus he has.
Oh yes.
There will be blood.”
I feel like there’s a Paul Thomas Anderson
joke to be made here, but I don’t know what
it is, so I’m just gonna put this humorous
if not irrelevant meme.
Alright, I think that’s been on screen for
long enough.
John explains to Matthews how he can see his
son again, if he simply sits and talks with
John until the game ends without resorting
to dirty police work such as…
“Evidence tampering.”
Ha, I bet you thought I was going to say,
"BRUTALITY!"
Matthews reluctantly agrees to sit down with
Jigsaw, who tries to get through to him and
make him realize the error of his past ways.
For how far John has strayed from his original
intention to help people, I do think he actually
does a good job during this game of staying
focused and doing his best to get Matthews
to actually win the game.
We also learn a little bit more about Jigsaw’s
mantra, the reason that he wants to build a
following and try to change da world.
He explains that Charles Darwin’s theory
of evolution no longer applies to the modern
man, because we live in a society where it’s
easy to survive without having the edge, or
will to survive.
That’s why John views his subjects as having
not cherished their lives.
Then he goes onto explain that his past, with
the cancer and the lost child changed that
for him, but before he’s able to give Matthews
that same epiphany, the detective walks away
in a rage.
That would be the closest John would get to
converting him to the church of Jigsaw.
Eric ends up resorting to destroying John’s
blueprints, which John points out is not the
proper move from an officer who should be
collecting evidence.
But John really wants Eric to succeed, so
he gives him another chance to turn it around.
Eventually, Matthews snaps when he sees a
criminal on the monitor coming after his son
and decides to go with his go-to method: “BRUTALITY!”
He breaks John’s finger, destroys the walkie-talkie,
which is basically his way of saying he won’t
be doing things by the book anymore, and puts
his gun into John’s mouth as he continually
threatens him.
At that point, John has seen enough.
He’s realized that Matthews is past the
point of no return, and that there is no hope
for him.
“Game… game over.”
Jigsaw realized that there was no hope for
Detective Eric Matthews after he turned a
violent hand against him, and decided it was
time to take him to the house where the Nerve
Gas Game had been held.
This was all part of his game plan though…
or I guess technically Amanda’s game plan,
though it’s hard to imagine that John didn’t
play a big part in it.
Because John’s most dangerous asset is,
unlike many other horror movie villains, his
intelligence.
We’ve seen him use his masterful understanding
of engineering to his advantage, but he was
also helped by an impressive comprehension
of the human mind.
To put it into a term that I find to be almost
comically appropriate, I would say that John
was a master of Game Theory.
“Hello internet, welcome to Game Theory.
So I’ve been doing some research and I found
out that what if Shaggy from Scooby Doo was
a stoner the whole time?”
Haha, no, that’s offensive.
I am not a stoner don’t do drugs or you
might wake up with a reverse bear trap.
But I recently learned that the beloved internet
show Game Theory is actually named after an
actual concept called Game Theory.
And yes, I do plan on continuing to pronounce
it like that.
GAME THEORY is the study of how players in
a game will strategize in different situations.
It’s basically the science of decision making.
The development of Game Theory was first developed
by mathematician John Von Neumann to try to
bolster his Poker skills.
John Kramer used some of those concepts to
make his games adaptable to some of the most
likely decisions that players may make.
He’s thought out most if not all possible
outcomes for each decision, but uses GAME
THEORY to determine which scenarios are most
likely to happen and spend the most time developing
those outcomes.
Yes, it is more complicated than that, but
as I’ve said before, we don’t do math
here in the Horror History classroom, so I’ll
leave it in the simplest terms.
John’s understanding of Game Theory is the
reason he was able to side-step Cecil, the
reason he could count on Zep to show up in
the bathroom and the reason that he was comfortable
putting his life on the line at The Wilson
Steel Plant.
When Matthews loses his game, John has already
predicted that Matthews will do what benefits
him most in the moment, by threatening John
and forcing him to give directions to the
Nerve Gas House.
John uses the fact that Matthews was thinking
independently from the rest of his unit to
his advantage; while John takes him to the
real Nerve Gas House, the police tech team
follows the video signal to another house,
where the pre-recorded videos are being played
back from.
Remember how I theorized that there were several
houses, all part of John’s Urban Renewal
Project?
I think the Fakeout Nerve Gas House is just another
one of these houses.
When John and Matthews arrive at the real
house, John is hanging onto his life by a
thread, and hands over a key, not disclosing
that this would be the key that locks in Eric
Matthews’s fate.
“Now you are locked away, helpless and alone.
Game over!”
🎵 "Forget To Remember" - Mudvayne 🎵
That’s my favorite one, if you can’t tell.
Amanda attempted to leave Eric Matthews for
dead, but Jigsaw, seemingly seeing great potential
in the guy and perhaps sensing that he was
close to getting through to him, decided to
give him one more chance.
He saved Matthews and kept him in a holding
cell for the next six months.
During this period, John realizes that he’s
running on borrowed time.
He knows his days are extremely numbered at
this point and he still has many targets that
he wants to punish.
Most importantly though, he still needs to
decide which of his disciples, now consisting
of Amanda Young, Mark Hoffman and Lawrence
Gordon, would continue his work after his
death.
He created games for each of them as a final
test.
Amanda’s game was planned to take place
with John on his deathbed, while Hoffman’s
would be a post-mortem challenge.
It’s not clear if Gordon’s final test
was detailed in the films.
It could be that the preparations he helped
with for some of the other traps were part
of his final test, or it could be that it
happened off-screen.
He also hoped to get his ex-wife back on his
side by showing her that his rehabilitation
methods had saved Amanda, even when the medical
approach at Jill’s clinic could not.
“I brought proof that it works.”
JILL: “Amanda?”
“Hello Jill.”
But there are way more planned traps and games
that Jigsaw didn’t have time for in his
lifetime.
He records a tape for his ex-wife Jill and
leaves it for her in his will, instructing
her to carry out a game to help balance the
power of Jigsaw when he’s gone.
This included Hoffman’s final test, but
also five others who were a part of William
Easton’s Umbrella Health, the insurance
company that had prohibited John from seeking
out alternative treatments to his cancer.
The box he leaves behind is locked so that
nobody without the key could get into it,
and he would hold onto the key for a while
longer.
He also makes pre-records the tapes that would
play during games and traps for other people
like Detective Kerry, a repeat offender named
Troy, SWAT Officer Rigg, a guy named Trevor
who we know nothing about, John’s former
business partner Art Blank, another pair of
tapes for Trevor and Art Blank in case they
survive the first one, a pimp named Brenda,
and evil Motel manager named Ivan, a pair
of abusive parents named Rex and Morgan, an
FBI Agent named Lindsay Perez, another FBI
Agent named Peter Strahm, five citizens who
all played a part in building fire scandal,
a malicious money lender named Simone, a malicious
money lender named Eddie, a sensationalist
reporter named Pamela Jenkins, a love triangle
consisting of three young people: Brad, Dina
and Ryan, a gang of four rap-metal lovin’
racists and the man who once tried to pretend
to be a Jigsaw victim would finally become
one: Bobby Dagen.
Keep in mind Jigsaw didn’t assume the outcome
of any game, so he also probably had multiple
tapes for each person to take all of the possible
results into account.
In addition to ALL OF THAT, he left one final
set of instructions that Jill was supposed
to hand off to Dr. Gordon.
“Watch over Jill.
And should anything happens to her, I want you to act immediately
on my behalf.
In return for that, I will keep no more secrets
from you.”
I hope old Johnny charged up some extra camera and audio recorder
batteries, because that’s a LOT of recording
going on for Jigsaw....
But not as much recording as I’ve had to
do to make this video, so with that in mind,
I think it’s only fair that I take a little
break before we get to the final game of John’s life.
It is likely that John knew the games taking
place in April of 2006 would be his last,
regardless of the outcome.
Two games would take place that day.
The one involving Rigg, Blank, Matthews and
Hoffman was designed by John, but would be
carried out mostly by Hoffman; while the other
game, involving Lynn Denlon, Jeff Denlon,
Amanda Young and John, was created by John
and would be facilitated by John.
The game was originally going to feature Jeff
Denlon going through a series of trials to
try to forgive the people involved in a road
accident that resulted in his young son’s
death.
The idea was that if he made it to the end
of the game, he’d be forced to confront
Amanda who is implied to be his captor.
Jeff’s restraint would be tested by choosing
whether or not to kill Amanda upon reaching
the end, while Amanda’s restraint would
be tested by making sure she didn’t sabotage
Jeff’s trial as she did to some of her other
victims in the past.
Jigsaw was worried that Amanda was only involved
because she enjoyed punishing the victims,
and did not want to see them actually succeed,
pass their tests, and rehabilitate as she
supposedly had.
Seeing Amanda sabotage her recent traps to
make them unwinnable disturbed John, and may
have made him start to lose faith in his methods;
or at the very least, lose faith in Amanda.
The entire operation he had built was founded
on the idea that Amanda had been the first
one to be rehabilitated, the prime example
of how suffering can cause a person to be
reborn and lead a better life.
He considered Amanda to be the closest person
to truly understanding him, so he would probably
be quite defeated if she were to fail her
final test now, after two years of training.
To make matters worse, she seemed to be developing
a rivalry with the other known prospective
candidate to continue John’s work: Detective
Hoffman.
Hoffman’s training with John was also ongoing,
and John did his best with the limited time
he had to teach Hoffman to walk the fine line
that Jigsaw is supposed to walk.
He must respect the lives of those test subjects
he captured, but also prepare to see them
suffer in order to achieve retribution for
their sins.
The day these games were held was April 28,
2006.
Before the fun begins, John’s ex-wife shows
up to the Meat Packing Plant to try to plead
with him and get him to stop his work.
Instead of listening to her, he gives her
the key to the box left to her in his will,
and tells her she will know what to do with
it when the time comes.
With that, John feels he’s done everything
he can do, and asks Amanda to take him to
his deathbed.
His final game was about to begin, and his
assistants went to retrieve the players, Dr.
Lynn Denlon and the mourning father Jeff Denlon.
Hoffman got done capturing Jeff and placing
him at the start of his trial moments before
Amanda got back with Lynn, and he used this
time to have one last meeting with John.
It turns out that Hoffman shared the same
concerns about Amanda letting her emotions
get in the way of giving her victims a fair
chance to survive.
John rewards Hoffman for his honest work so
far by giving him a protection that Amanda
does not have: anonymity.
Amanda was already a known accomplice to Jigsaw
-- the police and FBI would have figured that
out when they saw her help Daniel Matthews
out of the Nerve Gas House, since Daniel ended
up being stowed in Jigsaw’s workshop.
The FBI did suspect there was another accomplice,
but did not know with certainty that it was
Hoffman.
So John’s willingness to keep Hoffman’s
involvement a secret showed that he had more
faith in Hoffman than he had in Amanda.
In exchange for keeping this anonymity, he
does ask Hoffman to carry out one more task
and hands him a file with instructions on
a future game which would test Ashley Kuzon, Charles Salomon,
Britt Stevenson, Scott Mallick and Luba Gibbs, who all played some
part in causing and covering up a deadly fire.
*Jigsaw hands over the file*
Hoffman: “What’s this?”
JIGSAW: “It’s time to play a game.”
Those would be the final words John said to
his longest tenured student, who slipped out
a secret door before heading over to the room
where the final trial of Daniel Rigg would
take place.
Moments later, Amanda arrived with Lynn Denlon,
so their own game was about to begin.
“Hello Dr. Denlon.”
John explains that he was once her patient,
and blames her for telling him he’s going
to die in such a cold clinical tone of voice.
He claims that she is dead on the inside after
leaving her husband and neglecting her daughter.
But when John delivers his second most used
phrase from his list of 10 Top Phrases…
“What do I want?
I want to play a game.”
...he’s actually looking at Amanda, signifying
that this is her test as much as is it Dr.
Denlon’s.
This would be her final chance to prove she
can let a game play out fairly without her
desire for revenge and bloodthirst getting
in the way.
I mean, obviously there’s nothing fair about
any of Jigsaw’s games… but you get what
I mean.
When John states the rules, he simply says
he is testing her will to keep someone alive,
which could apply to both Lynn and Amanda.
Lynn is required to keep John alive, and Amanda
is required to keep Lynn alive.
If John dies, his heart rate monitor will
stop, causing Lynn’s shotgun collar to shoot her in the head;
whereas if Lynn dies, Jeff will come through
the door at the end of his trial and get revenge
on the first person he sees: Amanda.
The theme of the game is forgiveness.
Can a father forgive the people involved in
the premature death of his son?
Can Amanda forgive the victims who had faltered
in life as she once had?
And can Lynn Denlon forgive the man responsible
for the kidnapping of her entire family by
doing her best to keep him alive as long as
possible?
As usual with Jigsaw, each of these people
were pieces of his puzzle, and they would
all interlock together at the end.
His confidence that each of them will end
coming together is another example of his
mastery of GAME THEORY.
Amanda would keep tabs on Jeff’s progress
as Dr. Denlon began to treat John.
She believes John’s brain is herniating,
and suggests that they take him to a hospital,
and John watches helplessly as Amanda loses
her cool and goes off on the doctor, basically
telling her she needs to perform an operation
in this room.
Normally, Jigsaw would not really interfere
with anything that might change the result
of his games, but in this instance, he snaps
at Amanda.
I think that's because she was the only one
that had seemingly recovered from her addictions,
she was the only ray of hope that could make
John believe that his treatment methods actually
worked, so he desperately wanted her to pass
her test so that he could die thinking that
he actually had been helping his test subjects
all along.
Of course, John was completely delusional
at this point.
He hadn’t actually helped out anybody other
than himself, and would soon show much more
quantifiable signs of his deteriorating sanity.
But his sanity wasn’t the only thing that
had slipped, because moments later he would
go into a life-threatening myoclonic episode.
John must have been very aware that he was
getting close to the end of his life, because
it was very shortly after bringing Lynn Denlon
into the picture that he convulsed into a
dangerous state that required the combined
efforts of Dr. Denlon and Amanda to get the
oxygen flowing back to his brain and save
his life.
John was left very weak after this, but refused
to let that stop him from continuing to work
on his legacy.
He may have been crazy, but I gotta admire
this work ethic.
Just like you should admire my work ethic
to get you to buy this merch.
You can click in the link in the--
I think it was while Lynn and Amanda were
out arguing in the next room when Jigsaw recorded
the tape for Detective Hoffman to find after
his death.
Of course, he couldn’t guarantee that Hoffman
would be the only one to hear it, so he had
to speak in very general terms, not revealing
the fact that they were actually working together.
“Are you there Detective?
If so, you are probably the last man standing.
Now perhaps you will succeed where the others
have failed.
You think you will walk away untested?
I promise that my work will continue.”
John placed this tape next to his bed, and
as Lynn prepared for the next operation, Amanda
came in to inform him that Jeff had passed
through the first room of his trial.
John let Amanda know about an envelope that
he had Hoffman hide in his desk.
We never find out what this note was supposed
to say, it was most likely supposed to offer
Amanda some strength in words, but Hoffman
switched out the message.
If you want to know more about that, you can
watch the Hoffman and Amanda Horror History
episodes.
When he sees Amanda becoming overwhelmed with
emotion, he once again intervenes to try to
get her back on the right path.
“I can’t do this.”
JIGSAW: “Amanda!
You can.
You’re stronger now.
This is another example of his blind ambition
to prove that his rehabilitation process works,
despite all evidence pointing to the fact
that it doesn’t.
The American Psychiatric Association notes
that psychotic behavior can include an over-inflated
self image and extreme cockiness.
It seems that John has reached that stage,
and he can’t accept that he was wrong about
something, especially after spending the last
three years holding these games with the intention
of proving that his test-subjects were missing
something, and that torturing them in his
traps would help them find it.
After Amanda watches Jeff complete the next
room, she reports back to John, who is surprised
at the rate he is progressing, but despite
his quick advancement, the outcome of the
game would depend entirely on what was about
to happen next.
John gets a haircut, something that I could
use right about now.
ONE PANDEMIC LATER: If only you knew.......
in preparation of the brain surgery that Lynn was about to perform.
This would prevent the brain from pushing
up against John’s skull and theoretically
reduce his headaches and improve his motor
skills.
While it was possible to use numbing agents,
John had to be awake and alert for this procedure,
which involved Dr. Denlon drilling into his
skull and cutting open a window using this
little sawblade.
Get it?
Cause Saw?
That’s the name of the franchise…
“Ha, ha.
Ha…”
Something about this procedure triggers some
memories in his brain of a picnic he went
on when he was married to Jill, which he had
recorded on his camcorder.
I’m sure that tape is right there on the
shelf at home next to all his other home videos.
JIGSAW: "More comfortable in chains than you are in freedom."
During the hallucination, John tries to tell
his wife “I love you,” but that causes
it to look like he’s telling Lynn Denlon
he loves her, making Amanda get super jealous
and causing her to storm out.
“Just get out of here you stupid dumb animal.”
Once again, Dr. Denlon’s efforts are able
to buy John a little more time, and it seems
as if she’s actually starting to change
her attitude, for example we see her put her
wedding ring back on as if to suggest that
seeing John fighting for more time made her
appreciate her time with her husband.
Amanda is still in jealous girlfriend mode,
a very serious mental disease that I discussed
in great detail in her own Horror History
episode, and she comes in and starts kissing
John’s face and neck.
Lynn tells her that John is passed out and
he can’t hear her, and again, Amanda’s
temper flares up and she threatens to kill
Lynn.
Once again, Jigsaw has to intervene and scold
her… wait a minute John, weren’t you just
asleep?
So you mean to tell me you just gained consciousness
and had a full understanding of what was going
on in the two seconds between when this happened
and when this happened?
And you were totally passed out and not pretending
to be asleep when Amanda was all over you
right here?
I see you John Kramer.
I SEE YOU!
Meanwhile Jeff continues on through his trial,
eventually making it to the room where he
has the opportunity to save his son’s killer
from what John considers to be his personal
favorite trap: The Rack.
The fact that John even has a favorite torture
device is proof that he had developed a psychological
dependence on the feeling he got from hurting
others and that this was no longer solely
about curing people.
The trap is also a modern day crucifix, which
adds credence to his God-complex and development
of his teachings as a religion.
Back in the operation room, John asks Lynn
to talk about her husband, causing Lynn to
defend her marriage against him, which is
essentially what he wants.
He wants her to get passionate and take back
her life.
She begs for him to let her go free and right
as he takes her hand, Amanda walks in, causing
more jealous rage.
John sends her off…
“We’re fine Amanda.
We don’t need you.”
It does seem a little… counter-productive....
for Jigsaw to do something to piss off Amanda
like this when he really wants her to pass
her test.
It could be that he knew that she would have
to endure some emotional turmoil in order
to prove that she’s be able to handle her
emotions when he’s no longer around, but
I don’t think he was really in the mind
frame of giving his victims “proper” tests
at this point.
I think more what was going on is he sensed
he was close to a breakthrough with Lynn,
and didn’t want Amanda to interrupt it.
Why settle for one successful patient when
he could possibly have two?
“If you make it through this Lynn, you’re
going to thank me one day, just as Amanda
did.”
As he continued to talk with Lynn, he knew
that it would not be long before Amanda announced
that Jeff had passed through the final room
and would soon be headed to the operation
room.
With this, came the possibility that Jeff
would try to get revenge on his captor, so
it was time for John to hide the tape that
he had previously recorded for Detective Hoffman.
Since Amanda’s safety was also not guaranteed,
he covered the tape in a protective coat of
candle wax and swallowed it, so that the medical
examiners would find it in his stomach and
forward it to Detective Hoffman.
Sometimes when people know they are going
to die they get to have their favorite food
as a final meal.
John gets to have an audio tape covered in
wax.
So….
“The less we eats, the mores less fats we
get at ourselves.”
Not long after, Amanda would come into the
room to deliver the message that Jeff had
completed his final test.
This meant that Lynn had kept John alive long
enough to pass her test, and he orders Amanda
to let her go free.
Only Amanda has… other ideas…
“I said no.”
The Jeff Denlon Trials, as with the Barn Game,
The Bathroom Game and The Nerve Gas House
Game before it, end when the pieces of the
puzzle, the people involved with those being
tested come together; and as with The Bathroom
Game, this time they all literally come together
in the same room.
Amanda’s temper and jealousy had once again
gotten the better of her, and she refuses
to let Lynn go free after passing her test.
John knows he cannot directly say what will
happen if Amanda kills Lynn, but he does give
the warning that Lynn’s life is important,
because she controls the outcome of Amanda’s
life.
That ends up making Amanda even more upset,
and John tries to justify it by bringing up
the victims that Amanda had murdered, how
he had cleaned up her mistakes and forgiven
her, but how he will not allow her to go on
as a murderer.
Amanda argues that Lynn could not have rehabilitated,
because nobody they had tested ever really
changed.
She proceeds to shoot Lynn Denlon, and when
she does, Jeff is there to see it.
In retaliation, Jeff fires back and kills
Amanda.
With Lynn dying on the floor, Jigsaw has one
final final test for Jeff.
The lesson he had been trying to teach throughout
this entire endeavor was to forgive.
While Jeff had shown signs of forgiveness
in each stage of his trial, he was unable
to save any of the people involved in the
accident that resulted in his son’s death.
Now we would be faced with one more decision,
to exact his revenge on the man responsible
for putting him and his wife through even
more hell, or to let Jigsaw live in exchange
for a chance to save Lynn’s life.
After much deliberation, Jeff makes his choice.
“I forgive you…”
But in this case… forgiveness is not enough.
Even John, in the face of death, cannot help
but smile when Jeff fires up the circular
saw blade.
I think the irony of this twist was not lost
on him.
After all people who he had made suffer, it
would be one of his most tortured test-subjects
who would reverse that suffering back onto
him
And with a circular spinning Saw blade no
less, the very same type of weapon he used
upon his victims in the very first portion
of his first game at the barn.
It’s almost like that baseball game I brought
up earlier, where Aroldis Chapman gave up
the ALCS clinching home run, and all he can
do is give this weird smile, because he knew
that Altuve waiting on an off speed pitch
was no coincidence.
With his very last bit of life John rolls
Jeff’s tape.
“Hello Jeff.
I made this tape as an insurance policy if
you will.
… I was your final test of forgiveness and
if you are listening to this then you failed.
Now you must pay the price.”
The tape reveals that Jeff’s other child,
Corbett, is locked away somewhere and only
John knows the location.
By killing Jigsaw, Jeff had essentially locked
the tomb of his own daughter.
Even if John had lived, there is no excuse
he could have made to his followers for trapping
an innocent young girl just to punish Jeff.
So on the evening of April 28th, 2006, John’s
heart rate monitor flatlines, and the man
feared by an entire city as the Jigsaw killer
is no more.
With his death, Lynn’s collar goes off and
Jeff is locked inside the operation room for
life.
After years of insistence that his methods
worked, John died knowing that he had failed.
In early May, they would perform the autopsy
on John’s body and inside of his stomach
they found, not only John’s cocoa puffs,
but also the tape left for Detective Hoffman
who would continue to fill the shoes of Jigsaw
until March of 2007.
John’s body was buried in a local cemetery,
where it would remain until the year 2016,
when his first disciple, Logan Nelson, dug
up his casket and switched his body with that
of Edgar Munsen.
It is unknown where Kramer’s body currently
resides.
Throughout this video, we have discovered
the different puzzle pieces that make up the
life of John Kramer.
Just as he played games with his victims,
his own life, in a way, was a game where each
of these pieces came together to form an icon
named Jigsaw.
After a life of his own agony, he gave himself
the power to judge the lives of others, and
as a result developed a dependence on human
suffering.
This caused him to become a psychopath, the
likes of which rival the greatest serial killers
in all of fiction.
He developed a God-complex, and transformed
his work from a series of acts of violence
into a movement: a religion with its own symbols,
code of conduct and followers.
He claimed to offer all of his subjects a
second chance at life, but in reality, he
destroyed the lives of over 50 people, some
of which were bad criminals and some of which
were completely innocent.
He was able to get as far as he did based
on two things he did very well.
The first was his engineering degree, he was
a mechanical mastermind, making his traps
perfect machines that were only escapable
in ways that he intended.
The second was his ability to anticipate the
human mind, he was a master of game theory,
so every conceivable possibility for each
game, and really for anything he did in life
was already thought out and had a solution.
And what does that leave us with?
An almost finished puzzle.
Because with all of John’s intellect and
ability, he was never any better than any
of the people he tested.
Jigsaw was missing a vital piece.
If you’re a fan of Saw, click the playlist
on the left to see my Horror History analysis’
of other Saw characters.
And if you love horror, make sure you subscribe
to CZsWorld for new horrors every week, ring
the deathbell for notifications and I’ll
see you in the next one.
Assuming we both survive.